yeah because maybe that was going on and
all that like the samurais and all that
kind of stuff was going on like you know
i i just i don't know i mean you know
you think you know stuff about certain
culture
and you realize there's so much of it
that's just never exposed because we
only have this narrow view
of things and it's like the asian
culture for americans is always the same
[ __ ]
it's like i said ninjas samurais
kung fu kung fu masters yeah you know
that's like when i like when i was a kid
my only exposure to anything asian was
black belt theater on saturday mornings
with uh you know after the cartoons yeah
and i would love that [ __ ] the five
deadly venoms
oh five deadly animals the [ __ ] the toad
and the [ __ ] scorpion and yeah
i loved all that [ __ ] dude but that was
it
yeah because it's like and also imagine
growing up in like
suburbs i'm asian right and all the kids
are watching that kind of stuff
right and it's like and that has and i'm
like you know
listening to like punk rock yeah yeah
right yeah and doing my thing
right it has nothing to do with who i am
and so but then when you go out in the
world you know your your white friend
will come and take
and go hey buddy gotcha i was watching
you know that's [ __ ] sunday man
you know buddy and they'll come up to
you and do that stuff and you're like
whoa dude that [ __ ] hurt don't do
that again you know what i mean yeah
what are you doing right
or it's like you know um you walk into a
classroom and
your other friend will go everybody
watch bob's coming in right you walk in
they go
gong right and they'll go
they'll all go not not right
and you're i have a mohawk you know what
i mean america coming to the class yeah
yeah look like you have a sushi in the
basket shirt i know you got it i'm
walking
full of meth yeah yeah i'm going what
the [ __ ]
is this yeah and like you live in these
this world
here's my question for you bobby so up
until
recently like making fun of asian people
was kind of like like it wasn't looked
at the same
as how you would make fun of anyone else
like it was kind of like the the the
easy one and because it was like
non-threatening in a way it was like you
know and then you kind of think the idea
is like
asians are doing okay they got their own
towns and [ __ ] right here and
you know so it's okay to be like you
know asia's got a little dick or asian
destination that
but i feel like the cult there's been a
real
big culture shift now that it's like
it's on the same level now as making a
black joke or making uh
you know what i mean making a jewish
joke i think a lot of the younger
generation just isn't putting up with it
anymore
like isn't that what it is like you know
and i'm about to
bring up a comp a topic that's a little
uncomfortable but i have to
bring it up is you know i've been
struggling with what happened to tony
uh-huh hinchcliffe have we talked about
i don't think
i've never addressed it yet and um i've
been literally struggling with that
because on one hand
i understand what he was doing
you see the video yes and did you see
the whole video did you get the full
context of the whole
yeah yeah okay because i have my opinion
on it myself too yeah
my opinion is you know i've like i saw
um a comic a friend of mine a male comic
who's straight
bring up a gay guy on stage the other
night
and go one more time for the f-word the
f-word yeah right and they both laughed
right
and then the gay comic will say
something about the straight comic you
know i mean
you know that guy sucks dick or whatever
it might be right yeah there's they had
a rapport
they have a rapport right and there's a
culture there it's like you know i've
done it
like i used to have doc willis open for
me sometimes
and i just say something like gary
coleman you thought he was dead but he's
not you know i mean whatever
and then you you he says something back
and it's just a part of like
that thing and i think that with what
tony went through
right there's a lot of that in there
right because they because
because they know each other they know
each other but it was presented as if
he was some random asian cop an amazing
guy he didn't even know
and he just did that no no that and
that's what my that's what i took
offense to that
yeah well you took offense into what i
took offense to how
that was blown out of proportion against
tony yeah
now you know in this culture
it's like all right do you really think
that that was the way to do that
but even still that's his style
the roast battle the kill tony the stuff
that happens during that thing
that guy is a part of that and the guy
was doing hacky ass
jokes about white people before that
that was the
context of why he was what yeah and
that's why it got the laugh that it did
that's why
that's why people laughed right i
struggle with it i get it though i
struggle with it because i also
am like you know i want to be i'm very
pro-asian
and i also grew up in comedy where i was
bullied a lot in terms of
in the 90s i was the only one at the
clubs right so i would get
a lot of like white is this not
interesting to you no it's super
interesting oh yeah
you were drifting apart oh thank you can
i get a kleenex while we're in this
little
booger so i was like in in in the 90s i
was
you know you would have a cop no [ __ ] i
got
allergies yeah yeah yeah you would have
been a drill if you wanted you would
have comics say
um to your face yo man asians aren't
funny
get out of here or whatever right you
had that kind of sentiment right and
it's like
so i you know i'm the type of guy that
like when that happens i i don't give up
i go
i'll show you you'll get it you'll see
you know
so you know i i i get both sides but i
think in tony's
case it was more of a comedy thing you
know i mean and a culture
and a and i i can i get when people that
aren't in comedy
see just certain clips of that where it
could
look like real and at first i didn't see
the full thing i just saw
one little i didn't know they looked
really so i was mad
yeah i always live it but now that i've
like kind of explored it and understood
it
right i go you know what i'm giving tony
well it's layered man it's layered it's
layered because
there's just many different points in
here one that shouldn't have been
recorded and released
okay so that was some clout chasing
[ __ ] right there yeah
yeah yeah did he have someone in the
crowd yes yes okay so that's the that's
the number one
the fact that it was released but when
something if we're having a conversation
like even some of the stuff we were
talking about before we were on air for
this
if that somehow got released we know we
don't mean bad
but we would have to apologize for
when things get out it gets out so you
have to apologize for that because of
how it makes